so today was the lecture on scripting
and hosting it's the end of day three
this was probably the lecture that I was
the most prepared for in terms of
practice ahead of time ahead of this
class because it's kind of like what
George and I do for most of the
production process that happens for
science out loud so whenever we work
with our students in the individual
seasons this is basically what we do
with them just a little bit more
formalized and for a longer period of
time it is so hard to teach good hosting
because it's one of those things that
you can sit and read about and you can
watch a bunch of key studies and it just
doesn't matter until you try to adopt it
yourself I had planned all this material
or it would be like there were all these
videos of various hosts and it was going
to be sort of a similar exercise to day
one to all those youtube videos where
they would go through and they would
write you know some of the qualities
that they liked and tried to see what
they wanted to take on for themselves
but we just totally scrapped it and I
think honestly it was much better that
we did the hosting thing is hard and
helping the students really be
comfortable with their own voice in
their own persona on screen it's really
important so I don't want to distract
from that at all one of the students
wanted to minimize her presence on
screen I don't want the students here to
sell themselves short on on the power
that they have as a practitioner of some
of the signs in the engineering to to
default to a type of video that a lot of
other people can make these students are
not the best toast finding like a Neil
deGrasse Tyson at MIT you can't Bank on
that and I don't mean that in a mean way
perhaps I should rephrase this maybe
they can cut this out it is an imprudent
thing to assume that we're going to find
the next build
at MIT we can expect the students to
become like Hank green and to make the
next size show like that's an unfair
expectation to have but the value
proposition that they offer here which i
think is so powerful which i think is
the most important thing that someone
like Michael Stevens on Vsauce can't do
and scishow can't do is that they are
the scientists they are the people who
worked in the industry they are they
they are the actual naval engineers that
is something for me personally is so
important to highlight so to make
themselves evident I think is really
important to make themselves a host to
make themselves visible to to make their
persona and their actual personal
stories part of the video i think is
important whether you're in front of a
camera or you're on a stage or you're on
a podium giving a talk the habit of
falling back into this monotonous
robotic or perceived persona that you
think you have to take on totally
happens all the time so I think it's a
relevant lesson that people can take
with them after this class is over I'm
definitely rambling at this point maybe
it's because George did must have
talking today but I think it went good
thing you went okay